[Musique]
alors du coup du point de vue médical et
la psychiatrie de la santé mentale
on constate effectivement que les
étudiants seront une des populations les
plus touchées par entre guillemets vague
psychiatrique et la vague santé mentale
du covin alors c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaissait déjà par une grande pour la
dépression pas des reportages bidon avec
a appelé les étudiants à une population
plus vulnérable à la dépression mais là
dans cette crise qui fait qu' il ya une
des privations sociale qui est
importante que les populations précaires
sont plus précarisés l'étudiant sont une
population plus précaires et que
l'avenir apparaît un peu pas moins de 13
ans 1
les bouchers on voit que les étudiants
où justement la tête at il donné par
rapport aux parents est importante mais
elle fait traîner dans cet élan là et
donc on se prend trop particulière la
population étudiante est par sa nature
se fragiliser parce que relativement
précaire beaucoup de mal beaucoup de mal
à se projeter dans l'avenir voir dans le
présent cas certains pour qui sont
annulées au dernier moment
voilà il est très difficile de suivre de
garder le rythme
il ya évidemment l'isolément les
étudiants qui est qui qui sont logés
seul dans le parfum 9 mètres carrés très
éloigné de toute famille aujourd'hui de
tous amis oui je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce constat
je pense qu'il est bien en-deça des
attentes des étudiants bien en deçà des
attentes des étudiants parce qu'en fait
c'est traiter le problème à la surface
plutôt qu'à la racine c'est-à-dire que
les déjà le nombre de psychologues le
monde le psy qui va augmenter je crois
qu'il va doubler on souhaite passer à 1
pour quinze mille étudiants si j'en
crois les chiffres que j'ai lu il ya un
étudiant sur cinq qui pensent eux dans
le clip
mais aujourd'hui des pensées suicidaires
on est bien ou bien long de sa des
besoins des étudiants
et puis surtout les psys ne règle pas
tout les le mal être des étudiants
aujourd'hui il est bien plus vac bien
sûr que des pressions il ya évidemment
le côté médical le cip attribue aux
logiques et aussi le problème du
décrochage
les psys ne peuvent pas aider pour le
décrochage un étudiant sur six a été
contraint d'abandonner ses études cette
année
pour ce qui est du décrochage pour ce
qui est du suivi pour ce qui est du
suivi des cours pour ce qui est de
l'insertion professionnelle la grande
inquiétude quant à l'insertion
professionnelle
quant à la qualité des diplômes avec des
partiels tu sais ma distance qui en
réalité ne valent pas grand chose donc
je pense qu'en fait le problème bien
plus le linge qu'une histoire de psy-ops
on peut pas régler l'ensemble des
problèmes des clients actuels avec un
chèque qui m'a fait aimer liant en
revanche qu'on voit actuellement c'est
qu'il ya des gens l'étape et voilà des
gens qui ont besoin en fait de soins et
il n'y a pas d'accès aux soins parce que
la technologie n'est pas remboursé on
fait pour ces gens là ça peut être
extrêmement intéressant et pour aussi
cette frange de personnes il pourrait vu
dans basculer dans quelque chose de
pathologique
alors que si on met des moyens abandonné
en psychologie pour soutenir la personne
pour qu'elle puisse continuer à se
maintenir
bah du coup on évite justement le
bascule vers une pathologie poland
donc voilà moore en tant que psychologue
ou six médecins
on pense que ça peut être pas utile
d'avoir ça en cas d'urgence pour un peu
colmater les brèches et tenir les
personnes à bout de bras
[Musique]
une coordination à faire au niveau de
l'orientation des personnes avec
d'autres dispositifs prévenir c'est à
dire pour ceux qui sont en situation de
décrochage d'art quoi on les oriente et
ça c'est pas du tout une question
médicale et il ya aussi la question de
l'alimentation même basiquement des
étudiants actuellement son pré carré les
ailes qui ont causé une programme
privations alimentaires mais on va
pouvoir développer toutes sortes de
troubles donc des troubles fichiers donc
évidemment il faut un chèque qui pour en
urgence la soutenir des personnes qui en
ont besoin mais pour éviter que d'autres
personnes justement on est de voir où je
pourrais mettre en place des mesures qui
permettent d'éviter afin de soulager les
convictions adverse en laque à démouler
d'étudiants la seule solution à mon sens
c'est l'ouverture des sacs alors c c'est
un discours qui dérange aujourd'hui et
je le conçois mais l'ouverture des
amphis on peut on peut aménager à moitié
à cna tiers aca il n'empêche que les
étudiants ont besoin d'étudier sur les
bancs de la fac ont besoin d'être au
contact de quelques amis de quelques
professeurs l'apprentissage oz ou mans
tous les cas par lettre de l'audiovisuel
on perd énormément de données on perd
énormément de deux connexions de échange
une toque avec de l'humain à l'humain en
présentiel
en réalité d'ailleurs toutes les
organisations quasiment toutes les
organisations étudiantes quelques
détails près sont d'accord avec ce
discourt en réalité il faudrait ouvrir
les facs le plus petit
[Musique]